- Hey, this is Vinny Testaverde, and I am here to build my squad.
Now I'm gonna pick my all-time football lineup.
OK, my first pick at quarterback is
Tom Brady.
Well, I think Tom has proven himself.
He's one of the best, if not the best to ever do it.
Put him in any situation, any weather,
playoffs, Super Bowl, whatever the situation, he can handle it.
Running back.
Jim Brown.
You can even ask the greatest of the great running backs.
They'll all tell you Jim Brown was the best to ever play at his position.
Wide receiver.
Have to go with Randy Moss.
I would loved to have had Randy on my team to throw to.
So, I'm gonna go with Deion Sanders because
he was the best at it, and if you ask the fastest of the fast,
they would tell you that
they would never wanna play against Deion because
he can cover everybody.
And finally, linebackers.
I'll go with Ray Lewis because not only was he great, but
he's a former teammate of mine, and I love Ray.
Great player.
And if it wasn't him, it'd be Lawrence Taylor,
but there's a lot of comparisons between the two, but
Ray wins out because he was a teammate.
Locked in.
Quarterback, Tom Brady.
One of the best to ever do it.
Jim Brown at running back, the best to ever do it.
We got Randy Moss, who
nobody can guard at any era.
Deion Sanders, the fastest of them all.
Can cover anybody.
And finally, Ray Lewis.
I think I picked a good squad.
So, obviously I'm here for the Super Bowl this week,
and I've played my college football at Miami.
It's great to be back here, and I'm here with Straight Talk Wireless,
which is a prepaid, no-contract wireless service.
And last year during the Super Bowl,
fans streamed the event across 7.5 million devices.
And we're hoping that's even more this year.
And if you're looking to find out more information about it,
you can go to straighttalk.com.